انهجتهم جولات العمل المضنيه للحفاظ على
الحد الادنى من نظافه العاصمه بيروت
فهؤلاء قل عددهم بعد مغادره جميع العمال
الاجانب في الشركه وعلى الرغم من تعاظم
الحاجه الى اليد العامله فان الرواتب
انخفضت بشكل ماسوي ولا تشكل حافزا للعمل
في هذا القطاع
اذا بتشتغل بدنا 850 عام
اليوم نحن عندنا حوالي 450 ل 500 عمل يعني
اكيد حكما بتعرف انه نحن
انخفضت الاداء تبعونها على الارض احنا عم
نشتغل بالمينموم الكابستيه نقدر مستمرين
ونضلنا نرفع النفيات الازمه الاقتصاديه
دفعت عشرات الاف العمال الاجانب الى
مغادره لبنان لكن فئات اخرى اختارت البقاء
رغم ضيق الحال محمد واحد منهم ساعات العمل
الطويله حولته الى حبيس عمل لا يؤمن له
الحد الادنى من متطلبات العيش
العامله في قطاعات اقتصاديه عده لا
تعالجها مئات اجازات العمل للاجانب التي
تنجز وتصدر من وزاره العمل اللبنانيه ما
دفع الوزاره الى اتخاذ اجراءات للتكيف مع
متغيرات سوق العمل ان منصه للتوظيف في
وزاره العمل شفنا للمره الاولى هالقد في
بيكون اقبال العمال اللبنانيين بس هذا لا
يعني ان المرحله ورديه لا نحن في ازمه
اقتصاديه كبيره جدا وفي يعني في قطاعات لم
يكن ياتي اليها العامل اللبناني بعض اللب
الشباب اللبناني اصبح يقاربها
[موسيقى]